el juzgado a cargo de la investigación
por la desaparición de facundo astudillo
castro confirmó que unos restos hallados
a mediados de agosto en una zona rural
del sur de la provincia de buenos aires-
se corresponden con el joven de 22 años
así lo determinó una evaluación del
equipo argentino de antropología forense
facundo astudillo castro había
desaparecido el 30 de abril pasado
cuando viajaba desde la localidad de
pedro luro donde vivía en el sur de la
provincia de buenos aires- hacia la
cercana ciudad de bahía blanca para
visitar a su ex novia nunca llegó y su
familia no supo más de él en el camino
había sido detenido por la policía de la
provincia de buenos aires- y la familia
justamente señala a esta fuerza como
posible responsable de lo que le ocurrió
al joven y ahora será tarea de la
justicia determinar exactamente qué
ocurrió con facundo su dicho castro cómo
y por qué murió y por qué sus restos
terminaron en esa zona rural de la
provincia de buenos aires- cercana a la
ciudad de bahía blanca